>> THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PERSPECTIVE AND TIME.
OBVIOUSLY THIS STORY IS NOT
GOING ANYWHERE.
THANK YOU.
>>> NEW HAMPSHIRE REPUBLICAN
SENATE CANDIDATE CAMPAIGNED ON
FALSE CLAIMS THAT THE 2020
ELECTION WAS STOLEN AND THEN
AFTER WINNING THE NOMINATION
THIS WEEK HE CHANGED THAT TUNE.
>> I SIGNED A LETTER SAYING THAT
TRUMP WON THE ELECTION AND I
STAND BY IT.
I HAVE COME TO THE CONCLUSION
AND WANT TO BE DEFINITIVE ON
THIS.
THE ELECTION WAS NOT STOLEN.
WAS THERE FRAUD?
YES.
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS THE
LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT OF THIS
COUNTRY.
>> CNN ANCHOR AND CHIEF
WASHINGTON CORRESPONDENT JAKE
TAPPER JOINS US NOW.
WHAT CAN VOTERS TRUST WHAT DON
BOLDUC SAID AFTER SAYING THANKS
TO SOME RESEARCH?
>> YEAH.
IT IS VERY CLEAR THAT A LOT OF
CANDIDATES ARE EMBRACING DONALD
TRUMP'S ELECTION LIES TO GET
SUPPORT AND THEN WIN THE
PRIMARY.
YOU HEAR THE EXUBERANT CHEERING
FOR HIM IN NEW HAMPSHIRE A FEW
WEEKS AGO BUT THE REAL QUESTION
IS NOT JUST WHAT WILL VOTERS --
FOR VOTERS IN NEW HAMPSHIRE WAS
HE LYING THEN OR NOW?
IT IS REALLY IF THE 2024
ELECTION GOES TO CONGRESS WHAT
IS -- WHAT WOULD A SENATOR
BOLDUC DO?
CAN YOU TRUST HIM TO UPHOLD THE
RULE OF LAW AND THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION?
OR, DO YOU HAVE REASON TO
QUESTION THAT BECAUSE HE
EMBRACED DONALD TRUMP'S ELECTION
LIES TO WITH INTHE PRIMARY?
THIS IS NOT THEORETICAL.
THIS HAPPENED IN 2020 AND
JANUARY 2021.
AND THE FORCES OF MAGA ARE
SETTING THE STAGE TO DO IT AGAIN
EXCEPT SUCCESSFULLY IN 2024.
THAT'S WHAT'S BEEN VERY CLEAR
FROM THE JANUARY 6 HEARINGS.
>> YOU SAT DOWN WITH CONGRESSMAN
CHENEY TO TALK ABOUT THE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
ELECTION DENIERS RUNNING FOR
OFFICE FOR YOUR DOCUMENTARY
"AMERICAN COUP."
THERE'S CONCERN ABOUT WHAT
HAPPENED AND WHAT WILL HAPPEN
AND SEE ELECTION LIARS RUNNING
FOR OFFICE.
ARE YOU WORRIED?
>> VERY.
THE RESPONSIBILITY THAT WE HAVE
TO MAKE SURE TO DEFEND THE
REPUBLIC AND THE INSTITUTIONS
HAS TO BE ABOVE POLITICS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE RUNNING SO THAT
THEY'RE IN A POSITION THAT THEY
WILL BE ABLE TO CERTIFY THE
RESULTS ONLY FOR DONALD TRUMP.
THAT'S OBVIOUSLY FUNDAMENTALLY A
THREAT TO THE SURVIVAL OF THE
REPUBLIC AND THEY HAVE TO BE
DEFEATED.
>> YOU HAVE BEEN SHOUTING THIS
IS NOT JUST ABOUT 2020.
YOU ARE WORRIED ABOUT 2024 AND
FUTURE ELECTIONS.
>> I AM AND RIGHT NOW THE FORMER
PRESIDENT AND HIS ALLIES AND
SUPPORTERS INCLUDING IN CONGRESS
AND THE STATES REPRESENT A CLEAR
AND PRESENT DANGER TO AMERICAN
DEMOCRACY.
THAT'S NOT BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY
DID ON JANUARY 6.
IT'S BECAUSE OF WHAT THEY PLEDGE
TO DO IN 2024.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT REPUBLICANS
ARE HEAR WHAT YOU ARE SAYING?
>> I HOPE THEY ARE.
THERE'S NO EVIDENCE THAT THEY'VE
HEARD ANYTHING TO DATE.
>> HE HOPES THEY ARE.
NO EVIDENCE.
TELL US MORE WHAT TO LOOK
FORWARD TO IN THE DOCUMENTARY.
>> I WANT TO UNDERLINE THE
POINT.
TWO OF THE MOST CONSERVATIVE
REPUBLICANS IN PUBLIC LIFE
TODAY.
HE WAS ON PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
SHORT LIST FOR THE U.S. SUPREME
COURT.
THERE IS NO WORLD IN WHICH THEY
ARE NOT CONSERVATIVE.
ONLY REASON THAT THEY ARE ON THE
OUTS IN ANY WAY WITH REPUBLICANS
IS BECAUSE THEY STAND UP FOR
DEMOCRACY AND AGAINST THE LIES.
NOW TO YOUR POINT, TO YOUR
QUESTION, WHAT WE HAVE DONE IS
WE HAVE TAKEN THE ELEMENTS, THE
EVIDENCE, THE TESTIMONY FROM
THESE NINE OR SO HEARINGS THAT
THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE PUT
TOGETHER AND WE HAVE TAKEN IT
AND TAKEN IT DOWN TO ITS ESSENCE
SO THE PEOPLE NOT WATCHING ALL
THE HEARINGS AS WE HAVE CAN
WATCH THIS AND SAY, THESE ARE
THE FACTS.
THIS IS WHAT DONALD TRUMP WAS
DOING.
THE JANUARY 6 COMMIT TEE LAID
OUT THE SCHEME THAT TRUMP AND
ALLIES HAD.
LET'S LOOK AT THE EVIDENCE HERE
SO PEOPLE CAN WATCH AND MAKE UP
THEIR MINDS WHAT THEY THINK OF
WHAT DONALD TRUMP TRIED TO DO
BUT IT'S ALL VERY CLEAR.
THE COMMITTEE DID A GREAT JOB
AND TRYING TO PRESENT IT AS
COHERENT A FASHION AS POSSIBLE.
>> WE CAN'T WAIT TO WATCH IT.
AS YOU KNOW FORMER PRESIDENT
TRUMP WAS ON A RADIO SHOW THIS
WEEK AND BASICALLY SAID IF HE IS
INDICTED HE THINKS THAT IT WILL
CAUSE PROBLEMS LIKE WE HAVE
NEVER SEEN IN THIS COUNTRY AND
AFTER JANUARY 6 THAT'S A
BELIEVABLE STATEMENT.
DO YOU THINK THAT THE DOJ IS
USING THAT AS PART OF THEIR
CALCULUS?
>> NO.
DONALD TRUMP WILL MAKE WHATEVER
THREATS HE MAKES AND LOOK.
HE HAS A VERY ALLEGIANT,
OBEDIENT CORE THAT TAKES ORDERS
FROM HIM.
AND THERE IS NO QUESTION THAT
DONALD TRUMP'S THREATS ARE
CARRIED OUT BY HIS SUPPORTERS.
THAT'S ONE OF THE STRATEGIES,
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
CONGRESSMAN ADAM KINSINGER SAYS
IN THE DOCUMENTARY IS THAT IT IS
A FEATURE EPA NOT A BUG OF
TRUMPISM TO ATTACK THE MEDIA OR
A JUDGE OR A REPUBLICAN WITH THE
TEMERITY TO STAND UP AND SAY
DON'T UNDERMINE DEMOCRACY AND
THEN BESIEGED WITH THREATS.
HE ATTACKED ELECTION WORKERS.
THEIR LIVES CAN BE RUINED.
CONGRESSMAN KINSINGER SAYS
THAT'S THE POINT OF IT.
IT IS NOT JUST THAT HAPPENS TO
HAPPEN.
THAT'S WHY DONALD TRUMP DOES IT
AND USES THE LANGUAGE HE DOES.
HE COULD AS WITH THE JANUARY 6
INSURRECTION STOP IT AT ANY TIME
AND SAY, HEY, DON'T DO THAT.
I DON'T WANT ANY DEATH THREATS
OR GO AFTER THAT PERSON.
HE PICKS THE TARGETS AND WANTS
THEM TO BE AFRAID OF EVER
STANDING UP TO HIM EVER AGAIN.
>> WHY THE MESSAGE TO THE DOJ TO
BRING DOWN THE TEMPERATURE I